how AG tease calling cloud pulled off
that bonkers mind trick plus our Tyrese
and Drain Johnson in a fight hey friends
happy hump day I'm Danny direct oh and
there is a lot going on today on the
daily Deni
and alleged Tyrese beef with the rock
Jayla and her Kardashian obsession but
I'm starting with our favorite summer
show America's Got Talent
last night mind-reader calling cloud
blew the judges mind with what I like to
call what the magic it really was insane
he correctly predicted which celebrity
City and object the judges would pick
from a quadrillion number of random
tweets but here's the thing he predicted
which celebrity city and object they
would pick a week ago and recorded it
following them around with the answers
so I had to find out last night how he
pulled it off I wanted to do something
on the show that had never been done in
before and you know undercover hidden
cameras up how he does a lot to other
people and I thought you know what to
turn the tables and do it to him there's
gonna be interesting but best way to get
one over on how he is just to look
exactly like him and it worked he was
stalking yeah that bothers me and he had
your look he stole your look you know
that right
he went below is this me that's you this
is me yes he went me he was bald I
didn't know he was there I don't know if
he's here I don't know you don't know
now at any point were you nervous that
you would get caught I mean a week's a
long time yeah I mean the first night we
tested one of the disguises was actually
on the red carpet last week and we
thought right we'll do it in front of
all the press and see if anyone catches
on and I actually walked past this red
carpet four times by pastor
Matthew last week if you watch back the
footage wearing a hat pointing at it for
each of way too much footage that we had
to cut it right down but when it worked
on this red carpet and no one caught on
unlike right now I can go start
interacting with listen I told Colin I
would roll back on our footage from last
week and you guys he was not lying check
this out
that's him in the Hat now I know this
word gets overused especially by me but
I'm sure
now while we process that one let's turn
to Serena Williams leave it to her to
crush being a mom so hard that she puts
the rest of the world to shame this
morning mama Serena introduced Alexis
Olympia Ohanian jr. on Instagram making
her newborns social media debut she also
shared a sweet video diary of her baby
girl's journey to the world now if the
name sounds familiar it's because she's
named after Serena's fiance and reddit
co-founder Alexis Ohanian so she's still
a junior now in the video we see a
two-minute version of the pregnancy
through the eyes of both Serena and her
happy hubby all the way through the
baby's birth tennis fans will be happy
to learn that it looks like Serena kept
up her training all the way through and
in the birth announcement at the end of
the video the baby's name is featured
along with her September 1st birthday a
reference to her first Grand Slam win
that famously occurred by the way while
Serena was pregnant during the 2016
Australian Open all I gotta say is if
Alexis jr. has even remotely the talent
that her mother and aunt have on the
court you can look forward to this being
the first of many Grand Slam wins
all right let's dig it to what's going
on with Tyrese Gibson and Dwayne Johnson
it appears Tyrese went off on his Fast &
Furious co-star begging him not to let a
rumored spin-off starring only the
Rock's
agent Hobbs push back the planned
release date for fast night in a sense
to leave a comment on one of the rocks
instagrams Tyrese wrote I'm simply
trying to reach him cuz he won't call me
back
about this solo Hobbs movie I want you
to shoot it just not right now cuz the
fast dine release date has already been
announced
he added didn't you see how huge fast 8
was it's because we announced and kept
our release date bro Tyrese claims he
doesn't want to let down the loyal fast
family and fans and he also told Dwayne
that if he gets in touch with him he
would delete his comments so considering
they are all gone here's hoping these
two sorted this whole thing out
fast 9 is currently set to hit theaters
on April 19th 2019 but moving on to
Jennifer Lawrence whose new thriller
mother drops on Friday by the previews
alone I'm like nope too scary even JLo
says she's nervous her brother is gonna
walk out because it's so intense
Jennifer herself found there was only
one way to shake off the creepy
intensity when she was making the movie
take a look at what she said but I know
you had a Kardashian tent offset of this
film to help sort of I guess escape the
intensity of the role yeah why not a
housewives - um the Kardashians are more
comforting to me I think I've been
watching them for like 11 years so I
grew up with them I know all of them
personally
um the housewives you know they go in
and out they're fighting all that I
don't know maybe there's something more
comforting about the Kardashian that's a
good point I mean you get emotionally it
kind of been more invested in the
housewife shows you want to do a 10 of
the housewives I'd be like ah God LuAnn
what are you doing Ramona shut up
nothing screams comfort like Kim
Kardashian's cry face I don't know what
do you guys watch to decompress and
chill out let us know in the comments
section and head over to ET online.com
for more from our interview with
Jennifer and as always be sure to like
comment and share this video and thank
you guys so much for watching have a
great day